which live path is right for you when
you start a new game in cyberpunk 2077
you'll be asked to pick one of three
life paths street kid
corporate and nomad the path you choose
will affect the story
the characters you meet and the
conversations you might have we recently
had the opportunity to play the first
few hours of each life path so here's a
rundown of everything we know so far
be warned i will be talking about the
early hours of cyberpunk story so if you
don't want
any story spoilers click out of this
video right now
the street kid is a night city local
they were born
and raised in hayward under the stark
shadows of night city's neon drenched
skyline they know the
ins and outs of the city where to get
weapons drugs and
most importantly work the street kid
path kicks off in the el coyote coho a
dive bar located in hayward the
protagonist v
frequence unfortunately the bartender
has found himself in a sticky financial
situation with a local fixer named kirk
v agrees to chat with kirk to see if
they can convince him to soften the
bartender's debt
kirk tells v that if they can hijack a
car from a specific arasaka employee
he'll cancel the debt so v sets off to
hijack the vehicle
unfortunately someone else also wants to
get a hold of that car
a solo or mercenary named jackie wells
puts a gun in v's face as they're about
to drive off with the car
nothing personal copa just beers
but before either of them can make a
getaway the night city police department
ambushes them and detains both v
and jackie if the street kid
is the night city local then the nomad
lifepath is the foreigner
most nomads roam the badlands an area
outside of night city
in pax however v is a lone wolf their
nomad family is in shambles and v
is trying to put their own life back
together the nomad path opens up in a
backwater garage in the california
desert as v is getting their car
repaired but before v can leave a not so
friendly sheriff shows up
and questions v don't you know you owe
the sheriff a word
when you pay his town a visit when the
sheriff finally lets v go they head to a
nearby radio tower to contact a former
member of the nomad group we used to
ride with
from there v meets up with a solo named
you guessed it jackie wells in order to
smuggle a package across the border into
night city
as you approach the border jackie starts
to get cold feet and a border agent asks
v
to step out of the vehicle for an
interview of course this doesn't go as
planned and arasaka agents ambush you
and jackie a fierce vehicular gunfight
ensues both v and jackie ultimately
escape
and make it into night city
compared to the street kid and nomad the
kopo path seems almost
a little too clinical to be cool at
first glance corporations are of course
the bad guys but the journey of corpo v
is actually pretty exciting the
corporate path begins with v
throwing up in a bathroom sink in
arasaka tower where they currently hold
a job in counter intelligence
v is on the phone to jackie wells this
time a lifelong friend
venting about problems with their job
someone has leaked corporate intel and
everyone's on edge from there you meet
up with your immediate boss
jenkins who was infamous for being a
cutthroat dude and a bit of a prick
he drops the c word a bunch of times and
you watch him remotely massacre the
european space council
okay fair he's got some underhanded
plans in the works and forces you to
take part
giving you a wad of cash and ordering
you to discreetly hire someone
outside of the corporation to kill his
boss
abernathy v is super hesitant but takes
a flying car to meet up with jackie at
lizzie's bar to see if he'd be up for it
taking out a couple of basketballers in
the process this looked like a landing
pad to you
could have [ __ ] crushed us
okay no no hey we ain't looking for no
beef with you
unsurprisingly jackie thinks it's a
terrible idea and suggests cutting ties
but before too long a goon squad from
arasaka barges in
abernathy has caught wind of the plan
and her goons hack into your cybernetics
and wipe away
all of these corporate perks home
insurance and money
thankfully jackie stops them from taking
and killing v but now v's life has been
completely reset all they have is that
wad of cash and a best bud to help them
get back on their feet in night city
once you've completed the prologue
there's a time skip and all three life
paths merge into the main quest
cd projekt red said that each life path
has unique characters and quests that
you will experience as you play the game
some characters will appear in multiple
live paths however they will obviously
treat you differently and then there's
jackie wells
jackie will appear in all three life
paths and your relationship with him
will be slightly different depending on
the life path you choose in the street
kid path he starts out antagonistic to
the player in the nomad path he's an
ally based on circumstance and in the
corporate path he's a childhood friend
personally i plan on picking the nomad
path first
since like the nomad i've never been to
night city either
let us know which life path you plan on
picking when the game launches later
this year
[Music]
you